astralis have hired hundon yes that
hundon the heroic coach who got banned
for cheating
twice
yeah I mean uh
in the immortal words of xywoo
I don't know I don't know you don't know
okay
[Music]
okay so it's a new year which means it's
time for the annual hundin coaching
drama and boy are we starting early this
year last week perennial Danish
Powerhouse astralis announced that
they'd hired former heroic coach Hunden
as their head analyst was this
surprising I mean in one sense no since
there was a dexterto report last August
that he had been working for astralis
sort of off the books on account of his
e-sik ban which astralis subsequently
confirmed claiming that he was a
subcontractor who was making aim lab
content with their players or something
and yet in another sense it is a
staggering why
because of how Shameless it is for those
who don't know Nikolai hundon Peterson
is a long time Counter-Strike veteran a
former source and CS Go Pro he
represented the likes of Copenhagen
wolves and Matt Lions before taking up
the coaching mantle in 2020 and signing
on with the still nascent heroic and
that's where the trouble began you see
Hunden has had a head of a fraught
relationship with both the Esports
Integrity commission and by all outward
appearances
Integrity in general we've covered his
scandals yes plural extensively in
donami so if you want the full story
check him out but the gist of it is this
bro I gotta stop taking these on cam
back in the summer of 2020 hundon was
among the first wave of coaches to get
banned by esic which in hundon's case
was for 12 months later reduced to eight
for abusing the so-called spectator bug
heroic suspended him of course and then
in April of 2021 reinstated him right as
rumors began to spread that he might
actually be tapped to be Sonic's
replacement on astralis hundon then came
out and said that he wouldn't be
renewing his contract with heroic and
heroic responded by saying that they
would be taking legal action against him
I know for leaking strategic information
to a key competitor God hundon then
responded by going all it I'm
burning this down and saying psych
certain members of heroics roster did in
fact know about my use of The Spectator
bug and attempting to implicate them
e-sync was like all right this dude is
very suss and banned him for two entire
years in light of said Strat leaking
since according to them the team that he
was leaking to was one that he was also
in the process of negotiating a move to
I will give you 10 free 2020 RMR sticker
capsules if you can guess who that team
was it was astralis at this point it
just turns into the Real Housewives of
Global Offensive hundon releases
evidence against heroic's roster which
esik finds to be enough to hit Nico with
a minor sanction but essentially
exonerates the rest of the squad on
account of there being insufficient
evidence heroic then went full Barbara
Walters and released this raw tell-all
video where they talked about how
Capital was and tearfully told Hunden to
stick it where even turning your digital
Vibrance up to 90 won't do a lick in
terms of visibility shortly after
hundin's aforementioned off the books
working relationship with astralis came
to light and about five months after
that e-sik just mysteriously unbans
hundon on account of constructive
engagement between the two parties
seriously that's all we know all right
Jesus almost there so fast forward to
now January 2022 hundon is in spite of
all of this hired in tier one
professional Counter-Strike to be the
head analyst of none other
than astralis me dude I gotta start
making content about League dude no one
cheats in League like they're all
well-behaved dorks Counter-Strike is so
exhausting all right so what do we make
of all of this well I'll tell you this
much people across Esports
weren't exactly thrilled about this
signing and by that I mean people
weren't just stunned they were cheese
man legitimately ticked off this dude
has a well-documented history of alleged
and admitted wrongdoing in Esports and
it does seem ostensibly ruinous for the
very brand who supposedly helped enable
some of it to sign him on in spite of it
there is of course reason to think that
they could do well since as it happens
hundon and glaive go like Way Way Back
our very own Josh Murray actually talked
to hundon about his admiration for
glaive like two and a half years ago way
before this all started and the mind he
had about Sears was like
Totally Above everyone else like I
actually thought he was smarter than me
from from day one he was 14 years old I
guess and the way he was thinking about
the game the way he approached the game
was like just different from everyone
else I played with so the way it played
did the things in game and stuff like
that I trusted him 100 every time we
talked about CSN and play CS together
every time I needed a player or standing
or something like that I always called
him to like come and play with me see if
you're motivated to play and if you like
to still play the game and I think I
kept doing that for like six months or
something like that because we always
needed a standing and he was like okay
I'm coming I'll show up and play the
game but I'm not motivated to to join
the team right now will hundon helper
vitalize astralis from a strategic
standpoint I mean I don't know
does it matter I honestly don't think
anyone even cares at this point because
truth be told I don't have a ton to say
beyond that I know I'm cracking jokes
and all but even as I sit here
delivering a literal news piece about
this I'm sort of at a loss for words the
reality is there's not much more to say
Beyond just sort of sucks man I have
nothing but respect for the astralis
roster and support staff but this does
just feel like a really tone-deaf
signing that just spits in the face of
everyone in the community maybe I'm
overstating the point but I don't think
I am in any case if hundon does end up
engendering yet another proverbial
funeral and I really hope he doesn't
Laura knows
it'll be astralisis
do I think I could be a good coach I
like to mid-round call in CS so I feel
like I could be a good I feel like I'd
be a good coach obviously like dedicate
my literal life to like understanding
high level Counter-Strike yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah walk in tomorrow and be like all
right boys move over Sonic yeah yeah zyu
go kill